مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
اخبار الساعه مع العيال اختيار ابدؤها
بابره العناو
[موسيقى]
واشنطن تراقب اجتماعات موسكو وتعتبر
التحالف الروسيه الصيني موجها ضدها
تؤكد السيطره على معظم بخموت وزعيمها يحضر
موسكو من هجوم اوكرانيا مضاد نهايه الشهر
عمران يؤكد للعربيه ان القضايا المرفوعه
ضده اسبابها السياسيه وهدفها ابعاده عن
الانتخابات
المواجهه مع ترامب تتصاعد المدعي العام
لنيويورك قد يوجه لائحه الاتهام اليوم او
بعد غد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدي العربيه الى اخبار الساعه
انظار العالم مركزه على العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو التي تحتضن اللقاء الهام بين
الرئيسين الروسي
ونظيره الصيني في جنبي لقاء ياتي في توقيت
حساس وذلك على ضوء الحرب المتواصله في
اوكرانيا والتي خلقت وضعا سياسيا عالميا
جديدا فالصين ثاني اقوى قوه اقتصاديه في
العالم كانت من بين الدول التي تشبثت
بموقف الحياد تجاه الحرب حيث رفضت في اكثر
من مناسبه ادانه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
وما يزيد ايضا مشاهدينا من رمزيه زياره
الى موسكو هو التوقيت الذي يتزامن مع
اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره
اعتقال في حق بوتين مما يجعل هذه الزياره
تؤول وتحمل رساله تضامنيه معب
ودا كبيره للعلاقات الصينيه الروسيه وهناك
منطق تاريخي وراء ذلك لاننا اكبر دولتين
متجاورتين بالاضافه الى اننا شركاء
استراتيجيون هذا يحدد ان لدينا علاقه
وثيقه للغايه مع بعضنا البعض
صحيفه واشنطن بوسط الامريكيه نشرت تقريرا
مفصلا يخوض في خلفيه الزياره واهداف هذه
الزياره خصوصا انعكاسات الزياره على الحرف
اوكرانيا الصحيفه اعتبرت ان زياره الى
موسكو تعني تاييضا ضمنيا من الصين لتصرفات
روسيا وتشكل تاكيدا غير مباشر لتحالف بكين
وموسكو في مواجهه واشنطن والتي تبقى الخصم
الاول فيما فاذا كانت العداوه بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده قد تصاعدت بشكل واضح
بسبب الحرب الاوكرانيه فان الصين ايضا
لديها ملفات كثيره محط نزاع مع الولايات
المتحده وابرز هذه الملفات ملف جزيره
تايوان فضلا عن قضيه البالون والمسيره
الصينيتين اللتين تفجرت مؤخرا
لا شك مشاهدينا ان ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه
ياتي في طليعه الملفات التي تعكس التقارب
الصيني الروسي وذلك لعده اسباب فبعد بدايه
العمليه العسكريه لم تؤيد مذكر رسميا جهود
موسكو الحربيه وصورت نفسها على انها طرف
محايد كما حافظت في الوقت نفسه على
علاقاتها مع اوكرانيا لكن الصين قدمت
مقترحا مثل عشره نقطه لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا والمثير في انه لم يتضمن اي
مطالب لانسحاب روسيا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اما اقتصاديا فقد واصلت الصين
المبادلات التجاريه مع روسيا على الرغم من
العزله الاقتصاديه التي فرضتها الولايات
المتحده
وحلفائها من خلال العقوبات دون ان ننسى
المزاعم الامريكيه من ان الصين تقوم
بامداد روسيا بالاسلحه والذخائر وهو ما
نفته بكين بشكل قاطع
لقد درسنا بعنايه مقترحاتك لحل الازمه
الحاده في اوكرانيا
ستتاح لنا الفرصه لمناقشه هذه المساله
وسنناقش بالطبع كل هذه القضايا بما في ذلك
مبادرتك بشكل عام ونحن نعلم انك تنطلق من
مبادئ العداله ومراعاه الاحكام الاساسيه
للقانون الدولي انت تدرك ايضا اننا
منفتحون دائما على عمليه التفاوض
وسيسهم تفاعلنا على الساحه الدوليه بالطبع
في تعزيز المبادئ الاساسيه للنظام العالمي
وتعدد الاقطاب
وطبعا مشاهدينا لم يفوت الرئيس الصيني
الفرصه دون التنويه بالعلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه حيث اعتبر ان الصين وروسيا عززتا
الثقه المتبادله واسستا لنموذج جديد
للعلاقات بين الدول الكبرى على مدى العقد
الماضي كما اشاد بالمبادلات التجاريه بين
البلدين والتي بلغت 190 مليار دولار في
عام 2022
ودعى الى زياده نوعيه وكميه في الاستثمار
والتعاون الاقتصادي بين الصين وروسيا فضلا
عن تعزيز التنسيق في مختلف المجالات هذا
ووصف الرئيس الصيني البلدين بالرفيقين
متوقعا مساهمه البلدين معا في التقدم
البشري
في المقابل اكد البيت الابيض انه يراقب
اجتماع الرئيس الصيني شي جينج مع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مراقبه عن كثب
ودقيقه للغايه على حد وصفه هذا واكدت
اداره بيض بايدن رفضها لاي دعوات لايقاف
اطلاق النار قد تنتج عن الاجتماع الصيني
الروسي لان ذلك يعود بمصالح اوسع للرئيس
بوتين ويمنحه المزيد من الوقت للتجهيز
وتدريب واستئناف العمليات بحسب ما قاله
منسق مجلس الامن القومي للاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في الولايات المتحده
للحديث اكثر عن الترقب الامريكي لهذه
الزياره ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل
العربيه بيار هذا الترقب يعني الترقب عن
كثب كما تسميها الاداره لهذه الزياره ماذا
يحمل في طياته
اولا الامريكيون لديهم ثلاثه مطالب اساسيه
من هذه القمه بين شيوا المطلب الاول هو ان
يتمسك الرئيس الصيني بسياده الدول ثانيا
ان يطلب من الرئيس الروسي وقف القصف على
المدن
وثالثا يريد ايضا الامريكيون ان يتحدث
الرئيس الصيني الى الرئيس الاوكراني
ويستمع الى وجهه نظره ما يخاف منه
الامريكيون انت الموضوع قبل قليل هو ان
يصلوا الى تبند لوقف اطلاق النار يثبت
خطوط الاحتلال الروسي داخل اراضي اوكرانيا
السياديه وهذا ما لا يريده الامريكيون على
الاطلاق الغريب في هذا الموضوع هو ان
الامريكيين خلال الايام الماضيه ربما
حاولوا ان يوصلوا هذه الرساله الى الرئيس
الصيني ولكنهم فشلوا في ذلك لذلك يستعمل
المنابر اليوم تحدث وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بشان هذا الموضوع وايضا جون كربي
كما ذكرت قبل قليل اتيار يعني بموازاه ذلك
ايضا تصريحات الرئيس الصيني اليوم مع
الرئيس بوتين اعاده التاكيد بان هناك مساء
لخلق يعني نظام عالمي جديد
وتخطي الولايات المتحده عبر التحالفات
التي تحصل كيف ايضا ترى الاداره الامريكيه
هذا الموضوع
الامريكيون يعتبرون ان هناك خطراني عالميا
الخطر الاول هو الصين ولا خطر الثاني هو
روسيا
وتعتبر الاداره الامريكيه منذ سنوات انه
يجب مواجهه التصرفات الصينيه اكان في
افريقيا او في منطقه المحيط الهادئ
بالاضافه الى ان هناك دعوات كثيره لكي
تحترم الصين القوانين الدوليه وتتوقف عن
ممارسه الترهيب بحق جيرانها وخصوصا محاوله
اعاده احتلال تايوان بالقوه هناك بون شاسع
ضخم بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين من جهه وبين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وروسيا من جهه اخرى ولكننا
ننتظر ان يتحدث الرئيس بايدن الى نظيره
الصيني في وقت قريب جدا وهذا ما تسعى اليه
الاداره الامريكيه شكرا لك هذه المراسل
العربيه حدثتنا من واشنطن
وبعيدا عن المواضيع التي تهم موسكو بدرجه
اولى فان زياره لا يمكن الا ان تحمل اجنده
تخدم المصالح الصينيه فماذا يريد الرئيس
الصيني من هذه الزياره سؤال حاول الصحيفه
البريطانيه الاجابه عنه فتتوقع الصحيفه
هنا ان يستغل الرئيس الصيني الزياره
للدعوه مره اخرى الى انهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وذلك كخطوه دبلوماسيه للحفاظ على
تماسك العلاقات مع العسكر الغربي لكن وفي
نفس الوقت سيحاول تمرير رسائله المنتقده
للدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا وذلك لتشابهه طبعا
مع الدعم الامريكي
الصحيفه ذكرت ايضا ان رئيس الصيني وان كان
متشبثا برفض الدعم العسكري المباشر لروسيا
الا انه سيراهن على الدعم غير العسكري حيث
لا يستطيع الرئيس الصيني التخلي على روسيا
احد اهم حلفائه الاستراتيجيين في المقابل
فان
سيطمح ايضا في الحصول على مقابل لهذه
الزياره الرمزيه والمقابل تقول الصحيفه
هنا هو الحصول على او حصول الرئيس الصيني
على تاكيدات بان بوتين سيدعم هو دبلوماسيا
في حال نشوب اي صراع عسكري في تايوان اما
اقتصاديا فمن المتوقع ان تتم مناقشه مقترح
بناء خط انابيب غاز جديد بين روسيا والصين
فضلا عن تعزيز المبادلات التجاريه بين
البلدين اللذين انفتحا على بعضهما البعض
بشكل اكبر على خلفيه العقوبات الغربيه
من موسكو ينضم الينا استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الدكتور عمار قناه دكتور عمار
يعني بموضوع استفاده الصين من هذا التحالف
البعض يعني يعتبر بان سياسات الصين
الخارجيه حليف الصين الوحيد هو الصين نفسه
وبالتالي كل شيء يكون مبني على اساس مصالح
الصين اولا قبل اي شيء اخر كيف يعني يمكن
ترجمه هذه المقوله بالتحالف الصيني الروسي
اليوم
بانه يعني كلما طال امد الحرب كلما كان
هناك استعداد اقل لدول ممكن ان تدخل بحرب
ضد الصين وكلما طال امد الحرب كلما
استهلكت واستنفذت موسكو حلف الناتو هو
ايضا يعني يصب بمصلحه الصين بالرغم من ان
السلام الاقتصادي اليوم هو مصلحه لها ايضا
المساله العسكريه ليست يعني هي الاولويه
اليوم يعني في هذه العلاقه او في اهتمامات
الصين الصين يعني كما ساعدت منذ البدايه
هي تسعى الى استقرار يعني المنظومه
الدوليه لانه فقط من خلال يعني هذه الحاله
ممكن التوسع بالمشاريع القوميه الصينيه
واهمها يعني طريق الحزام يعني والطريق
والذي الذي لا يتناسب مع المصالح
الامريكيه ضمن الهيمنه الاقتصاديه الغربيه
على على العالم لكن النقطه الاساسيه وهي
التوافق حول انتقال يعني المنظومه
من الاحاديه الى التعدديه القطبيه وايضا
يعني المحافظه على عدم يعني مفهوم او عدم
تجزئه الامن في العالم هذه المساله ايضا
هي مهمه جدا للصين ضمن القضايا المطروحه
او الخلافيه ما بين الولايات المتحده
والصين في المرحله الحاليه النقطه اليوم
الرئيس الروسي وكانه يبني تحالفاته
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والعسكريه
يعني بمعزل عن الغرب وطبعا بظل الاعداء
الموجود مع مع الغرب والحليف الاساسي هو
احد اركان النظام العالمي الاساسيين وهي
الصين هل ممكن ان تسمح يعني الولايات
المتحده
بتماد هذا الحلف على المدى البعيد
سؤال مهم جدا سيدتي الكريمه لكن يعني لا
ننسى انه من دفع بهذه العلاقه وتكثيفها
باعتقاده هي نفسها الولايات المتحده بناء
على الاخطاء الاستراتيجيه التي قد
ارتكبتها خلال الفتره الماضيه وهي التصعيد
في نفس الوقت يعني جزئيا عسكريا في
اوكرانيا مع روسيا وايضا تجاريا واقتصاديا
والتلويح بالورقه العسكريه مع مع بكين
فهذه هي الحاله التي يعني حصلت عليها
الولايات المتحده من خلال يعني محاولاتها
الحفاظ على احاديه
القطبيه باعتقاد اليوم يعني النفوذجات
المتحده بدا يتقلص نوعا ما في اكثر من
منطقه في العالم وايضا يعني في مساله يعني
العلاقات او شكل على علاقات الذي بدا
يتشكل في المرحله الحاليه هناك حالات لم
نكن نتوقعها يعني ممكن مثل ظواهر يعني ان
العالم بدا يرفض الاملاءات الامريكيه
واليوم نرى التالف الائتلاف الغربي ايضا
هو في حاله انقسام اليوم العالمي ينظر الى
الولايات المتحده بانها على استعداد
للتضحيه
بالزحلفاء الاستراتي على كل حال يعني
الاساس اليوم بعد مغادره الرئيس الصيني
لاي مدى سيكون مرتاح بوتين لجرعه الدعم
الصينيه شكرا لك دكتور عمار على هذه
المداخله
مشاهدينا تتابعونا في اخبار الساعه ولكن
بعد قليل الامم المتحده تؤكد ان نصف مليون
سوري دون ماوى جراء الزلازل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد هل تقترض معركه بخموت من
نهايتها سؤال لاحق بالافق بعد التقدم
الروسيه الاخير في المدينه فنقلا عن قائد
قوات فاجنر الروسيه فان 70% من المدينه
باتت تحت سيطره قواته هذا وحذر قائد فاجنر
في الوقت ذاته وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه من
ان اوكرانيا تخطط لهجوم مضاد نهايه الشهر
الجاري وتبقى مشاهدينا مدينه بخموت هي
محور القتال الشرس في الحرب في اوكرانيا
وذلك في ظل تواصل المعارك بها منذ اكثر من
سبعه اشهر
ويبدو بان القوات الروسيه لم تنجح فقط في
التقدم في مخلوط بحث بل حتى في مناطق اخرى
وتحديدا في افديفيكا بدونيست فنقلا عن
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه فان القوات
الروسيه حققت مكاسب في ارديفكا مؤكده ان
الوضع التكتيكي في المدينه يشبه ما يحدث
في بخموت ولفتت الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تواصل الدفاع المنظم لكن خطوط الامداد الى
الغرب مهدده بشكل متزايد من قبل عمليه
التطويق الروسيه
[موسيقى]
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه قال وزيره التجاره
السعوديه الدكتور ماجد القصبي ان المملكه
وشعبها استقبلوا بكل ترحيب ما وصلت اليه
العلاقه مع طهران واضاف وزير التجاره
السعوديه بان ايران بلد جار وان المملكه
تدفع بكل الجهود الراميه للتنميه
والاستقرار والسلام
المملكه وشعب المملكه والمنطقه استقبلت
بكل ترحيب ما وصلت اليه فايران ايضا جار
وندعو الله ان ان يديم هذا الاستقرار وان
نركز على التنميه وان ينفع بكل الجهود
التي تبذل السلام والاستقرار
وزير التجاره السعوديه اكد بان ولي العهد
السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان وجه بانجاح
العلاقات مع العراق على كافه
انا اعتقد انه اليوم العلاقه في اكمل
اوجاعها والظروف كلها مهياه الظروف
السياسيه الظروف الاقتصاديه الظروف حتى
الاجتماعيه كما تعرف العراق اليوم
جار وشقيق ولغه ودم وتاريخ وحنا النسيج
الاجتماعي السعودي العراقي نسيج مشترك
وكل
المكونات موجوده وكل السبل لنجاح هذا
العلاقه موجوده وفعلا انه توجيه سمو ولي
العهد العمل هذا الشيء ووضعنا فعلا مشاريع
محدده
وجاري الان متابعه كل المشاريع وبعضها
يعني مشروع بعض المشاريع ان شاء الله
ستسمع عنها قريبا
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران
خان ان عشرات القضايا مرفوعه ضده لاسباب
سياسيه واضاف خان في مقابلات خاصه مع
العربيه ان الهدف من هذه القضايا هو
ابعاده عن الانتخابات
هناك نحو مئات قضيه مرفوعه ضدي وهذه
القضايا تشمل مزاعم التحريض والارهاب وحتى
قضايا قتل حيث اتهموني بقتل شخص كل هذه
القضايا وراءها دوافع سياسيه لابعاد على
الانتخابات فالمشكله هي ان المعارضه تعرف
تماما انها لا تستطيع الفوز بالانتخابات
ومن بين الانتخابات الفرعيه البالغه عددها
37 مقعدا فزنا ب 30 منها فهم قلقون من ان
مشاركتنا في انتخابات الثلاثين من ابريل
ستلحق الهزيمه بهم وهم يخشون من ذلك وهم
يحاولون ابعاد عن سباق الانتخابات من خلال
اقامه كل هذه الدعاء وضدي
خال قال للعربيه ان الحكومه لم توفر له
الحمايه خلال جلسات المحاكمه وان حياتهم
مهدده ورغم ذلك حضر كل الجلسات باستثناء
واحده بسبب اصابته خلال محاوله اغتياله
الاخيره
سبق ان حضرت جلسات المحاكمه كلها والمره
الوحيده التي تخلفت فيها عن الحضور كانت
بعد اصابته اثناء المحاوله التي تعرضت
فيها للاغتيال والتي حاله دون الذهاب الى
المحكمه لمده اربعه اشهر لكنني كنت مقعدا
في البيت بسبب اصابه في قدمه قبلها كنت
اذهب الى كل جلسات المحاكمه مع عدا واحده
وسبب ذلك هو ان مبنى المحكمه غير امن فهم
لم يوفروا لي الحمايه وحياتي كانت مهدده
على الرغم من ان الحكومه اعلنت ان حياتي
مهدده الا انها لم توفر للحمايه وفي تلك
المحكمه حصلت قبل ذلك عمليتين ارهابيتين
نجمتا عن مقتل قضاه ومحامين وعندما نقلت
المحاكمه الى المجمع القضائي ذهبت الى
هناك يوم السبت ومثلت امام هيئه المحكمه
تتابعنا مشاهدينا المقابله الكامله التي
اجرتها الزميله رينبوغامرا مع رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان يوم
الاربعاء في تمام الساعه السادسه عشر
بتوقيت غرينتش والسابعه بتوقيت الرياض
[موسيقى]
كشفت منظمه الامم المتحده بان السوريين
باتوا مهددين اكثر من اي وقت مضى بالفقر
والعنف واضافت المنظمه الامميه ان حاجات
التاهيل العاجله في سوريا تتطلب ميزانيه
تتراوح بين بين سبعه و تسعه مليارات دولار
حسب البنك الدولي هذا واشارت المنظمه الى
ان السوريين يواجهون العنف والكارثه
الصحيه ومخاطر الكوليرا والافاق المظلمه
وبالعوده الى زلزال الذي هز شمال شرقي
البلاد اشارات الامم المتحده الى ان نصف
مليون سوري
وان تسعين بالمئه من السوريين يعيشون تحت
مستوى الفقر
رئيس الوزراء السويدي اعلن ان مانحين
زوليين تعهدوا في بروكسيل تقديم سبعه
مليارات يورو لمساعده سكان تركيا وسوريا
المتضررين من زلزال السادس من فبراير
المدمر والى اليمن حيث اكد المبعوث الاممي
الى اليمن هانز جراندر بريك ان وفدي
الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثيين اتفقا على
تبادل
887 اسيرا اضافه الى العوده الى في شهر
مايو القادم لاستكمال المفاوضات حول صفقات
تبادل اخرى
اختتم اليوم بنتائج ايجابي اتفق الوفتان
على خطه التنفيذ
للافراج عند 887
محتجز من الجانبين
اتفقوا اذا على الالتقاء مجددا في منتصف
ما يلي بحث المزيد من الاسرى الذين
سيفرجوا عنهم
وتم ايضا التركيز على السماح بالوصول الى
كافه الاسرى
الطرفين اللذين يتواجدان اليوم
للحوار البناء والتفاوض بحسن نيه لتوصل
الى هذه النتيجه من خلال تنازلات الضروريه
[موسيقى]
لمجالاتكو انها سيتم بحث وصول الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ترامب الى المحكمه مع
جهاز الخدمه السريه والشرطه نيويورك وان
قرار الاصفاد او قرار وضع الاصوات في يديه
ترامب من صلاحيه المدعي العام لمن هاتن
ومن جهاته قال حاكم فلوريدا انه لن يتورط
في عمليه تسليم ترامب الى سلطات نيويورك
ووفقا لمسؤولين امريكيين فانا اجراءات
التخطيط الداخليه للتعامل مع الرئيس
السابق سيكون باعتقاله اذا لم يستسلم
هو محامي عمل لمصلحه دونالد ترامب منذ
2006 حتى مايو 2018
في يونيو 2018 بدا تحقيق فيدراليون ضده
ودين عام 2019 بجرائم تشمل التهرب الضريبي
والكذب على الكونجرس وتسهيل مدفوعات غير
قانونيه عام 2016 رتب لدفع 150 الف دولار
لشراء حقوق قصه العارضه السابقه كارين
ماكدوغل التي زعمت فيها اقامه علاقه مع
ترامب عام 2016 ايضا سربت له مقاطع مع
ترامب حول قضيه كارين عام 2003
استعداده للشهاده ضد ترامب في قضيه شراء
الصمت ستومي دانيت
قصب العاملون في اداره شرطه نيويورك حواجز
خارج مكتب المدعي العام لمنطقه من هاتف
لمدينه حيث يتوقع ان تشهد المدينه
احتجاجات لانصار الرئيس السابق ترامب اثر
صدور لائحه اتهامات بحق وفي وقت سابق قالت
ترامب انه يتوقع ان يقبض عليه يوم
الثلاثاء لسبب نزاعا بدفع نقود لنجم
اباحيه في عام 2016 وحث انصاره على
الاحتجاج
في معرض رده حول استعداد مدينه نيويورك في
حال صدور لائحه اتهام ضد الرئيس ترامب قال
عمده المدينه ان الامر متروك للمدعي العام
وان السلطات تراقب حتى وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وذلك اثر تخوف من احتجاجات
حاشده لانصاره ترامب
الامر متروك
وسمعنا الكثير من التقارير لكن المدعي
العام سيتخذ هذا القرار ونحن سنفعل ما
نفعله دائما كما تعلمون نحن نراقب
التعليقات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وتؤدي شرطه نيويورك دورها الطبيعي في
التاكد من عدم وجود اجراءات غير لائقه في
المدينه نحن على ثقه اننا سنكون قادرين
على القيام بذلك
قد تبدو هذه الاجواء هادئه لكنها اشبه
باجواء ما قبل العاصفه عاصفه رياحها
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
ان سيطر على شاشات التلفزه بدعوه انصاره
لتنظيم احتجاجات حاشده
الاحتجاجات المرتقبه اقلقت السلطات
الامريكيه من تكرار سيناريو اقتحام
الكابيتول الاميركي على يد مناصري ترامب
وامكانيه خروجها عن نطاق السيطره وتحولها
الى عمليات عنف وتخريب وفيما يشبه الهجوم
المضاد ندد رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن ماكارثي بتحقيق المدعي العام بحق
ترامب واصفا الامر بالمسيس رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن ماكارتي
لا يهم اي جانب من المشكله انت الان لا
يهم ما اذا كان هذا هو الرئيس ترامب او
اذا كان ديمقراطيا يجب ان تكون هذه عداله
متساويه في امريكا وان تتوقف عن ملاحقه
الناس لان لديهم خلافات سياسيه
دعوه ترامب للتصعيد في الشارع رافقها
تاييد من كبار المسؤولين ابرزهم
السيناتورلينز دراهم الذي حثت على
المقاومه واخذ القضيه الى المحكمه العليا
تصعيد الجمهوريين قابله اخر ديمقراطي
بدعوى ان ما يجري محاولات جديده لخدمه
مصالح ترامب
السيناتور الديمقراطيه اليزابيث ورن
هذه حاله اخرى
لمصالح
لنكن واضحين بشان ما يحدث هنا لا احد فوق
القانون ولا حتى الرئيس السابق للولايات
المتحده
التصعيد الحاصل بين جمهوري وديمقراطي يبقي
الشارع الاميركي ومعه العالم مترقبا لما
سينتهي اليه الامر امر قد ياخذ امريكا الى
ابعد من هذا المشهد
[موسيقى]
يسعى نتنياهو الى اجراء تغييرات في السلطه
القضائيه من شانها ان تمنح الحكومه او
حكومه تتنياهو نفوذا اكبر في اختيار
القضاه وتحد من سلطه المحكمه العليا في
الغاء التشريعات هذه الخطه مشاهدينا اثار
التظاهرات ومواجهات استمرت لاسابيع حيث
وصف معارضها نتنياهو بانه يحاول تقويض
استقلال المحاكم لكن مع تراجع نتنياهو ما
هي ابرز هذه التعديلات يظهر مشروع القانون
المعدل انه لا يمكن تعيين اكثر من
القاضيين في المحكمه العليا خلال تصويت
اعتيادي في جلسه واحده بالكنيسه التعديلات
الجديده التي تم ادخالها تشير الى انه
سيتم توسيع لجنه الاختيار الى تسع من تسعه
الى 11 عضوا كما هو مقترح في الاصل ولكن
مع تركيب تمنح الحكومه نفوذا الاقل
المشروع المعدل ايضا استخدم لغه اكثر تحفظ
ا مقارنه لتلك الوارده في مشروع القانون
الاصلي لكن ما تزال سلطه القضاء القضاه في
لجنه الاختيار محل جدل خاصه فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه استخدام ما اعتبر حقن قد تلقائيا
على الترشيحات
لمنصه القضاء
اعتبر الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تصريحات وزير
الماليه الاسرائيليه بشان الفلسطينيين
خطيره وغير محترمه ودعا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه للتنصل منها في مقاله الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه ان التصريحات العنصريه لوزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي التي انكر فيها وجود
الشعب الفلسطيني هي محاوله لتزييف التاريخ
وتزويره التقرير التالي للزميله روان حمزه
وقراءه رياضه عاشور
اسبوعان تقريبا يفصلان بين تصريحين
اسرائيليين فجرى غضبا داخليا وادانات
خارجيه واسعه بعد دعوه وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
طلب فيها بمحو بلده حوار الفلسطينيه يعني
اعتقد ان قريه حوار بحاجه الى محو اعتقد
ان اعلى دوله اسرائيل ان تفعل ذلك
استفزت داخل الفلسطيني قال فيها ان الشعب
الفلسطيني اختراع لم يتجاوز عمره 100 سنه
لا يوجد فلسطينيون لانه لا يوجد شعب
فلسطيني السلطه الفلسطينيه صارعت للتنديد
بتصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي المتتاليه
الرئاسه وصفتها بتزييف للتاريخ ودليل على
عنصوريه الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي تنكرها
فيما رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شتيه
استنكر تصريحات
ووصفها بالعنصريه والتحريضيه دليل قاطع
على الفكر الصهيون العنصر المتطرف الذي
يحكم اطراف الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
ورغم التمديدات الداخليه والخارجيه بتصعيد
غير المبرر لتصريحات العدائيه يقف رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتانياهو
موقفا صامتا ولا يضع حدا له
امر قد تبرره خبايا المشهد السياسي في
اسرائيل
فنتنياهو كون حكومته من ائتلاف حرج يضم
فيه احزاب اقصى اليمين يخشى ان يؤدي صدامه
مع سبوتريتش الى انهيار ائتلافه وبالتالي
حكومته بالكامل هنا قد تكون اسباب استمرار
تجاوزات رئيس الماليه الاسرائيلي واضحه فو
الزعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
ونتنياهو لا يرغب في خساره تاييد حزب نافذ
فمحاوله معارضته قد تكلفه خساره السلطه
اعتمد البرلمان الفرنسي قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد وذلك بعدما نجحت الحكومه او نجت
من تصويتين لحجب الثقه عنها امام مجلس
النواب وتمكنت حكومه ماكرون من النجاه
بفارق ضئيل حيث صوت 278 نائبا لصالح سحب
الثقه وهو اقل بتسعه اصوات عن المطلوب
لحجب الثقه وتواجه الحكومه هذا التصويت
بسبب رفض قانون التقاعد الذي قدمه
اذا مشاهدينا نتابع واياكم هذه الصور
المباشره لاستمرار عمليات التظاهر في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس حيث بدات اعمال
الشغب خلال المظاهرات احتجاجا طبعا على
رفع سن التقاعد والذي اصبح معلوم من 62
عاما الى 64 عاما والذي تم تمريره يعني
بدون
رغبه المواطنين الفرنسيين ومع اعتراض كامل
من قبل النقابات واحزاب اليمين ايضا
اذا هذه الاحتجاجات التي ما زالت مستمره
منذ ايام والتي بدات على جولات متعدده نحن
نتحدث عن اكثر من سبع ثمان جولات منذ ان
بدات الحكومه مناقشه هذا القانون قبل ان
يصبح قانون وصفه اعتراض تام من قبل الشعب
الفرنسي على هذا التعديل
اذا هذه التحركات المستمره تاتي وسط اسرار
الحركات النقابيه هناك التي نسقت
باجتماعات متتاليه على عدم الخروج من
الشارع حتى تحقيق يعني اي خرق او استماع
الحكومه لمطالبهم وست طبعا تشدد الحكومه
بهذا الموضوع وهو القانون الذي كما يعني
نذكر بانه تمريره بدون تصويت مجلس النواب
عليه بسبب علم الحكومه بانه لن يمر هناك
وبسبب ايضا عدم امتلاك اي من الاحزاب
الاغلبيه داخل مجلس النواب
تتابعنا مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه بعد
قليل البرلمان الفرنسيه يعتمد قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد
[موسيقى]
اذا يبدو مشاهدينا ان الولايات المتحده قد
تواجه توجسا رقميا جديدا مصدره الصين
ويتعلق الامر بتطبيق ينتمي نفس الشركه
التي تمتلك تطبيق تيك توك المحظور من
الاجهزه الحكوميه الامريكيه الحديث هنا
مشاهدينا عن تطبيق كاب كات الذي تمتلكه
الشركه الصينيه الام بيضات
الذي يعد اداه لصناعه الفيديو عبر
الانترنت شاهد انتشارا واسعا في الولايات
المتحده حيث تم تنزيلها في الاسابيع
الاخيره اكثر من تيك توك الذي وجهت اليه
اتهامات في بعض الدول بخصوص الوصول الى
بيانات المستخدمين
ويسمح كاب كات للاشخاص بتقطيع مقاطع
الفيديو بسهوله باستخدام العديد من
القوالب والمؤثرات المرئيه والموسيقى
ويقول هنا المستخدمون انه يساعدهم على
انشاء مقاطع تبدو اكثر احترافيه ول فرص
افضل للانتشار مقارنه بتيك توك ومنصه اخرى
هذا وتم اطلاق في عام 2020 هذا التطبيق
ولديه الان اكثر من 200 مليون مستخدم نشط
شهريا ومقره
وقفز حجم تنزيل هذا التطبيق بنسبه
43% في العالم كما ان الولايات المتحده
تستحوذ على 7% من هذه التنزيلات
للحديث اكثر عن هذا التطبيق ينضم الينا من
كاليفورنيا البروفيسور احمد بنافع الخبير
التقني والاستاذ الجامعي في كاليفورنيا
استاذ يعني عندما نتحدث ايضا عن خطر جديد
للتجسس وللبيانات التي تعتبر تصنف تحت
خانه الامن القومي الامريكي هل يمكن ايضا
حظر هذا التطبيق وبالتالي حظر كل
التطبيقات الصينيه
انتقلت العمليه من مجرد انه ننظر لي على
انه فقط بيحسن الفيديوهات او بيديهم
مؤثرات خاصه يعني
بسيط على الاشياء اللي هذا التطبيق بعينه
يعني بيجمعها من جهاز المستخدم بيجمع
كيفيه استخدامه موقعه بيجمع كمان الملفات
اللي موجوده فهو اطلاع كامل على جهاز
المستخدم فهنا هي مشكله الامن القومي
اذا المشكله بانه يعني لديه الولوج على
كافه البيانات الشخصيه داخل الهواتف ولكن
عندما نتحدث عن هذا التطبيق هل يعني هل
يمكن ان تذهب السلطات الى حضروا وبالتالي
حاضر كل التطبيقات الصينيه
الاتجاه الان انه بيضغطوا على تيك تاك
وعلى الشركه الام على انه يتخلصوا من
تابع للصين او للشركه الصينيه بحيث انه
تصبح كل البيانات موجوده هنا في امريكا
الواقع اللي احنا فيه الان انه البيانات
موجوده في امريكا وموجوده في سنغافوره
يعني هذا هذا بناء على المعلومات منهم
فاذا منعوا تيك تاك بقيه التطبيق حيكون
سهل عليهم يمنعوه لان العدد اقل من تيك
تاك تيك تاك منتشر للان وصل 150 مليون في
امريكا
كبيره
اذى التطبيق الذي كنا نتحدث عنه يعني
لماذا يلجا اليه الناس وما الفائده منه
يعني هو ليس معروف كتيك توك طبعا
صحيح انا انا يعني
حملت التطبيق اول يعني اول شاشه قابلتني
بيسالوني هل ممكن ادخل على ملفاتك بما
فيها الصور والمعلومات كلها بعدين لما
استخدمته يعني السهوله والمؤثرات اللي فيه
شيء عجيب يعني تقدر انت تعمل الفيديو هذا
بطريقه بحيث انه محترفين يعملونها اضافه
الى انه عنده خاصيه بانك ممكن تنقلها الى
المنصات الاخرى مش بس تيك توك فهذا هو
اللي جذب الناس لها يوتيوب وفيسبوك وغيرها
وبالتالي لديك يعني
جهاز بيدك ممكن ان تفعل فيه اي شيء طب
اليوم لماذا هذه التطبيقات الصينيه
رائجه اكثر بالاسواق لماذا استطاعت ان
تقدم ما لم تقدمه التطبيقات الاخرى وهل
صعب مثلا على انستجرام او غيرها بان تقوم
بخلق تطبيقات مماثله
سؤال جيد جدا الفرق هو الذكاء الاصطناعي
الشركه الصينيه هذه ادخل الذكاء الاصطناعي
في كل منتجاتهم هذا التطبيق اللي تفضلتي
وذكرتيه اللي هو كاب كات من 2020
فما كان له صيد الا لما دخلوا فيه مساله
الذكاء الاصطناعي ونفس الاسلوب في تيك تاك
ونفس الاسلوب في كل التطبيقات تبعتهم هذا
السبب ان المستهلك يجد انه التطبيق
بيفهموا وبيوصلوا النتائج احسن من
التطبيقات الثانيه
التطبيق يفهمه هل هذا يعني بان التطبيقات
الصينيه عندما يتم يعني العمل عليها تاخذ
بالحسبان اكثر ذوق الناس تاخذ بالحسبان
اكثر متطلباتهم اليوميه وليس فقط
المتطلبات الربحيه للشركه وهي طبعا تعود
بالفائده على المشترك وعلى الشركه بنفس
التوقيت
كلام سليم جدا لانه من ضمن الاشياء اللي
التطبيق بيجمعها معلومات عن طريق
الاستخدام شركه الاتصالات التي يستخدمها
نوع الجهاز نفسه اشياء كثيره انا عندي
قائمه طويله من هذه اللي بيجمعها هذه
بتساعده على انه لما يعرض عليك المحتويات
او يعرض عليك القوالب اللي تستخدمها لها
معنى عندك انت شيء خاص بالبلد اللي انت
فيها اضافه الى انه هذا التطبيق بعينه عمل
مسابقه في امريكا مين يدي له قوالب جديده
ويدفعولهم الف دولار مقابل كل واحد من
القوالب هذولا
الدمج يعني حتى بتيك توك مع العلم ان
الكثيرين يقولوا بانه تطبيق تافه ولكن اذا
استمعت الى الاولاد ماذا يتعلمون من تيك
توك هو هي فعلا معلومات عميقه وليست تافهه
ابدا ولكن طريقه التوصيل هي بطريقه مبسطه
الدمج بين المعرفه وبين التسليه وبين
الربح بتطبيقات الصينيه والذي هو غير
موجود التطبيقات الاخرى لماذا
فهموا نفسيه المستخدم لانه لو نظرت
للتطبيقات الثانيه بتعتمد على تاريخ
ومعامله الشخص او المستخدم ما عدا
التطبيقات الصينيه بيستخدموا على الذكاء
الاصطناعي اللي بيفهم نفسيه الشخص ويستخدم
كل المعلومات اللي موجوده في الجهاز حتى
يوصلوا الى الصوره او الى المقطع اللي
بيفيده سواء اخبار او او مثلا افلام او او
اي نوع من المقاطع هذه اللي هو بيكون عنده
رغبه انه يشوفها وهذا الفرق بينهم وبين
التطبيقات الامريكيه شكرا لك احمد بنافع
الخبير التقني واستاذ الجامعي في
كاليفورنيا
[موسيقى]
انطلقت اليوم اذاعه العربيه اف ام من
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض والتي تقدم تغطيه
للاخبار السياسيه والاقتصاديه والرياضيه
على مدار الساعه اضافه الى رصد ومواكبه
الاخبار العاجله محليا وعالميا وتضم
الاذاعه شبكه من المراسلين في جميع انحاء
العالم
وراء كل خبر قصه تروى تدقيق ورصد بالصوره
شاشه يمتد عمرها لاكثر من عشرين عاما ان
تعرف اكثر مهمه العربيه من عام لاخر الان
جاء دور الصوت والكلمه من العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض ولدت اذاعه العربيه
العربيه اف ام تضعك في الصوره لتعرف اكثر
ومن قلب استوديوهات الاخبار بالرياضعه
العربيه تكمل الصوره خبرا لكل المستمعين
تصلكم حيثما كنتم اسرع من اي وقت اتمنى ان
يصلكم الخبر فور حدوثه واينما كنتم بالصوت
والكلمه سنقدم لك كل ما يهمك ان تعرفه عبر
صباح العربيه اف ام
لطالما كانت الفكره وتفرد المحتوى هما حجر
الزاويه منذ نشاه العربيه تواصل الاذاعه
المشوار بخطه ثابته في بث يمتد عبر الاثير
والوسائط المتعدده الى مستمعيها في العالم
اجمع
عصام عبد السلام اذاعه العربيه اف ام
مشاهدينا الى هنا ناتي الى ختام اخبار
الساعه المزيد عبر منصات العربيه شكرا
لحسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]